bienvenue dans vue de Russie votre
magazine hebdomadaire qui analyse la
propagande de Vladimir Poutine sur fond
de guerre en Ukraine avec comme chaque
semaine Elena Volochine bonsoir Elena
bonsoir Stéphanie deux semaines après le
putsch avorté de yu-gene prigogi contre
le pouvoir de Moscou vous allez nous
montrer comment la propagande russe gère
les suites de ses événements oui
Stéphanie mezavant nous allons parler de
la frappe à vif c'était hier c'était
entre dans la nuit de mercredi à jeudi
pardon la Russie a tiré une salve de
missile longue portée depuis la mer
Noire sur cette ville de l'ouest de
l'Ukraine c'est missiles ils ont détruit
plus de 30 immeubles dont des immeubles
d'habitation bilan à ce stade au moins
10 morts 42 blessés dont trois enfants
et hier soir les principaux journaux
télévisé russes donc comme toujours pas
dit un mot de ses victimes civiles
regardées par exemple le grand journal
télévisé russe de 21h sur la première
chaîne russe pi avec un an
les forces armées russes ont frappées
les réserves stratégiques des forces
armées ukrainiennes sur le territoire de
l'Académie des forces terrestres alvave
là où ont atterri 8 missiles de
croisière calibre étaient stockées 45
unités blindées de l'OTAN parmi elles
ont Stan britannique challenger dans les
casernes de l'Académie était logé près
de 800 combattants ukrainiens et
mercenaires étrangers
cette nuit les forces armées de la
Russie ont mené une frappe ciblée avec
des armes de longue portée de haute
précision basée en mer contre des lieux
de dislocation temporaire des effectifs
des forces armées ukrainiennes et des
mercenaires étrangers ainsi que des
lieux de conservation de véhicules
blindés de fabrication étrangères
toutes les cibles définies sont
détruites les buts de la frappe sont
atteints les réserves stratégiques de
l'ennemi ont subi une perte
significative voilà des frappes de haute
précision contre soi-disant des
combattants ukrainiens et des
mercenaires étrangers 499 jours de
guerre en Ukraine est toujours pas un
mot des victimes civiles sur les chaînes
de télévision russe les médias répètent
mot pour mot les communiqués monotone du
porte-parole du ministère russe de la
Défense Igor conachenkov les images
montrées sont toujours celles des
départs de tir mais jamais des
conséquences réelles les Russes qui
s'informent via leur chaîne de
télévision ne savent toujours pas que
l'opération militaire spécial de
Vladimir Poutine est une guerre et que
cette guerre tue presque chaque jour à
des civils ukrainiens
et samedi 24 juin le chef de la société
militaire Wagner marché sur Moscou on a
tous vu les images avec son armée de
mercenaire il a finalement fait
demi-tour après qu'un accord a été
négocié par l'intermédiaire de Alexandre
lucaschenko alors comment le régime
russe gère-t-il cette crise de semaine
après ce putier et bien avec l'aide de
sa propagande qui a aujourd'hui trois
mots d'ordre 1 c'est glorifier l'image
de Vladimir Poutine de démonter celle de
yevini Prigogine et 3 épargner celle des
combattants de Wagner dont le régime
russe encore besoin alors voyons d'abord
le premier volet Vladimir Poutine il est
présenté comme le vainqueur absolu d'une
opération qui a sauvé la Russie son
culte de la personnalité et décuplé
depuis cette crise regardez l'ouverture
de l'émission phare du dimanche soir
vesti midi et sur la chaîne et tatie
crush Rossi à 1 elle est présentée par
une star du petit écran de mithique qui
s'élove
la cohésion de la Russie est un fait le
pays sort renforcé de cette épreuve
d'un côté une trahison évidente et de
l'autre l'unité absolue du peuple et de
toutes les branches et niveau du pouvoir
la cohésion autour du président de la
Russie pas une seule compagnie de
l'armée n'a soutenu la rébellion sous la
direction de Poutine toutes les forces
et les services de sécurité ont réagit
vite bien de façon coordonnée
professionnelle et son ombre d'une
hésitation le pays s'est adressé comme
un monolithe en soutenant son leader qui
plus est après une expérience si extrême
la Russie en est sortie plus renforcé
nous avons tous reçu une piqûre de
rappel contre de telles aventures
comprenant ce qu'il en coûte et comment
elles peuvent se terminer le héros
incontestable dans tout ça c'est le
président et une nouvelle fois nous
pouvons louer Poutine et sa capacité à
agir dans un moment critique
il a organisé une résistance profonde si
bien que personne ni au pouvoir ni parmi
les forces de sécurité n'a même eu
l'ombre de la panique
voilà pour la légende on n'a pas
vraiment vu cette résistance du peuple
russe grand accent
d'ailleurs les Russes un de cette crise
on a vu aucune image de gens par exemple
sortir dans les rues pas plus que l'on a
vu ses actions héroïques décrites des
forces armées russes pendant la
rébellion elle-même on n'a pas vu
beaucoup d'images en fait en dehors de
cette succession de vidéos enregistrées
des messages d'allégeance à Vladimir
Poutine diffusé par les médias russe de
la part de dignitaires et haut
fonctionnaires du régime il y a aussi eu
cette cérémonie d'hommage aux militaires
qui ont soi-disant résisté à l'assaut
des Wagner et dimanche soir l'émission
hebdomadaire Moscou Kremlin Poutine qui
est toujours entièrement dédié au culte
de la personnalité du président et les
revenus sur cette cérémonie en diffusant
des images que l'on n'avait pas encore
vu et des interviews de militaires à
grand renfort vous allez le voir d'effet
de style pour souligner le rire
[Musique]
les tirs sur la place historique des
cathédrales c'est en l'honneur de tous
les Russes qui comme jamais se sont unis
en ces jours et aussi en l'honneur des
militaires et des gardiens de la paix
qui immédiatement se sont dressés pour
défendre le pays on s'est réveillé on a
pris notre petit déjeuner et là on a
reçu une mission prendre nos armes nos
munitions et notre équipements et sortir
effectuer un entraînement militaire je
suis resté 10 heures allongé l'arme
pointée sur un pont j'attendais l'ennemi
alors vous avez bien entendu cet élève
d'une académie militaire a été envoyée
pour repousser l'armée de mercenaires de
yevini Prigogine à titre d'exercices il
dit qu'il était prêt à défendre sa
patrie mais que l'ennemi n'est jamais
venu alors selon la légende racontée
dans une autre partie de son émission
par Mitry et seloff à quelques centaines
de kilomètres de Moscou yves-geni privé
de répondre aux appels téléphoniques du
président biélorus Alexandre lucasenko à
ce moment là l'aviation militaire russe
ce serait élevé dans les airs pour
frapper non pas la colonne de prix
gaugine mais des frappes préventives à
côté de la colonne pour inciter
Prigogine à décrocher son téléphone et
c'est à ce moment là que Prigogine est
bien il aurait décroché répondu à
l'offre de refuge du président
mais hier Lucas and Co a dit que
Prigogine ne se trouvait pas en
Biélorussie mais à Saint-Pétersbourg où
il a son QG celui de sa société Concorde
de la compagnie Wagner et ce qu'il
faudrait sans doute qualifier d'ancien
usine à troll puisque l'État russe parle
de démanteler carrément son groupe
médiatique oui Stéphanie et ses lieux
ils ont fait l'objet de descente et de
perquisitions alors on ne comprend pas
encore très bien si des poursuites
judiciaires sont engagées ou non contre
yefghani privé on ne comprend pas bien
non plus si ces effets personnels comme
par exemple tout son arsenal et célias
de billets qui ont été saisis lui ont
été rendus parce que les propagandistes
russes il se contredisent à ce sujet
avant-hier en tout cas les médias russes
ont montré les images de ces
perquisitions dans le business center de
Prigogine et chez lui des armes donc des
liasses de billets de la drogue des
lingots d'or des faux passeport et même
des perruques tout ça ça a été montré et
passer au crible par les propagandistes
russes dans les médias russes ieveni
prigogne est désormais l'homme à abattre
regardez
en ce moment les téléspectateurs de
rosiens voient ces images pour la
première fois personne ne les avait
jamais vu nulle part regardez cette
opération unique des forces de sécurité
voilà le nid de Prigogine sur ces images
on voit son bureau et cette fourgonnette
dans tout le monde parle cet argent se
cache ce liquide pris que le garder
comme ça dans sa cave d'où ça vient
aucun document ne le montre
hier les médias disaient que l'argent
lui avait été rendu comment peut-on lui
rendre ce sont des pièces à conviction
dans le cadre d'une enquête pénale ils
ont dressé des procès-verbaux tout est
scellé seul le tribunal peut décider
Poutine a d'ailleurs même admis que pris
gojin avait reçu son argent de l'État
russe oui 858 milliards de roubles de
contrats pour la société Wagner 845
milliards pour le groupe Concorde qui
gère notamment les affaires africaines
et la gigantesque machine à propagande à
travers le groupe médiatique patriote
cette machine qui a aussi tourné à plein
régime au profit de l'État russe c'est
en tout cas les informations que
communiquer dimanche soir Dimitri qui
s'éloffre dans son émission quant à
cette émission qui a montré ce qu'elle
présente comme des images exclusives des
perquisitions elle rappelle étrangement
un film celui consacré au palais de
Vladimir Poutine il a été réalisé par
l'opposant russe aujourd'hui emprisonné
à l'excès Navali on voit ces images à
l'écran vous savez que le credo d'Alexia
et navalys était la lutte anti
corruption et donc en 2021 il a réalisé
ce film 127 millions de vues sur Youtube
une enquête qui dévoilait la grandeur et
la démesure du palais de Poutine sur les
rives de la Mer Noire au sud de la
Russie 17000 m² sur un territoire grand
comme 39 fois la Principauté de Monaco
alors
avant-hier sur la chaîne hépatique
Russia 1 qui évidemment n'avait pas
diffusé le film de Navalny ont montré
d'autres images il s'agissait bien de
montrer aux Russes comment vivaient les
mafieux corrompus sauf que le palais
n'était pas celui de Vladimir Poutine
mais une demeure un peu plus modeste
celle de yefghani Prigogine regardez
le palais de celui qui lutte contre la
corruption et la criminalité
voici le palais c'est juste sa maison
hélicoptère et pourquoi pas tout homme
qui se respecte doit avoir un petit
hélicoptère dans sa cour des Dollars Des
Devises un hélicoptère un palais 600
millions d'euros 600 millions chez un
combattant pour la justice
alors par lutte contre la corruption ce
journaliste il fait référence aux
déclarations
de marche de la justice sur Moscou à
savoir lorsqu'il dénonçait le clan
oligarchique au pouvoir qui a déclenché
la guerre en Ukraine problème Prigogine
il mordait la main qui le nourrissait et
ce journaliste qui commente Edouard
Petrov il le sait parce que depuis la
fin des années 90 c'est-à-dire à peu
près l'arrivée au pouvoir de Vladimir
Poutine il est spécialisé Edouard Petrov
dans les affaires criminelles et il sait
non seulement que prigogi est un mafieux
étroitement lié au clan de Poutine mais
aussi que les tarus lui a donné carte
blanche à ce mafieux pour recruter des
criminels dans les prisons et aller les
envoyer combattre en Ukraine du coup
alors que l'ordre est donné aux
propagandistes de salir l'image de
prisogine ce journaliste Edouard Petroff
il s'emporte et il va un peu trop loin
regardez cette séquence elle a un peu
longue mais elle est importante pour
comprendre comment fonctionne la Russie
de Vladimir Poutine
un homme ordinaire ne peut pas avoir
autant de passeports il faut tirer ça au
clair qui lui a délivré ses passeports
comment pourquoi cet homme avait-il
autant de prérogative brûle est acquis
strane
et pourquoi de nombreux journalistes
ont-ils oubliés d'en parler qui lui a
donné le droit de ramener des
multirésidivistes sur le front vous
savez les gens qu'on a interviewé ils
ont comédie green lourd ils ont été
condamnés pour avoir tué 10 15 personnes
ces gens on les avait filmés en prison
et puis on les a vu sur la ligne de
front et beaucoup se sont retrouvés au
cimetière
Édouard une loi a été adoptée qui permet
aux prisonniers de signer des contrats
avec le ministère de la Défense
les prisonniers mais pas condamnés pour
crime grave vous en souvenez je
comprends pas comment on peut donner la
possibilité à quelqu'un qui a tué 12
personnes d'aller intégrer un bataillon
se passe pas comme prévu les
propagandistes russes indignes mais il
ne doivent pas dépasser certaines
limites Elena comme par exemple
critiquer le régime oui et en
l'occurrence aussi s'ils doivent
démonter l'image de prix gaugine ils
doivent aussi épargner celle de Wagner
car les tarus a décidé de ménager ses
combattants et là le présentateur il y a
gagné Popov du coup et bien il se charge
toujours de recadrer son chroniqueur
regardez
tout le monde le savait tout le monde
savait que Prigogine a été condamné deux
fois qu'il avait un passé criminel qu'il
était fiché par les services de lutte
contre le crime organisé on ne pouvait
pas
écouter la société Wagner content de
mission à succès en Afrique en Syrie
bien sûr chez Wagner certains avaient du
Mérite
la plupart la plupart des gens de Wagner
ont accompli des exploits ils ont pris
des villes ils ont servi honnêtement et
ils ont payé le prix du sang ils se sont
rachetés par le sang
les Wagner la plupart d'entre eux sont
des héros qui les armes à la main ont
défendu notre patrie
voilà donc la ligne narrative des médias
russes aujourd'hui c'est de dire que
tout est de la faute de yefghani
Prigogine qui a trahi tout le monde non
seulement son pays mais aussi ses
propres combattants les wagnères les
Wagner eux sont des pins comme des héros
les criminels de guerre et de droits
communs évidemment il pose un immense
problème aujourd'hui de sécurité pour la
Russie puisque des crimes plus ou moins
violents sont déjà recensés dans les
régions russes ils impliquent des
anciens prisonniers rentrés du front
mais les condamnés pour crime lourd et
bien ils bénéficient désormais de remise
de peine en récompense d'aller
participer à l'opération spéciale vous
avez entendu des pénis pop dire ils ont
payé le prix du sang on leur installe
même des plaques commémoratives il y a
déjà des cas dans les régions russes et
des monuments où ils sont célébrés comme
des héros lorsqu'il meurent au front et
on l'a vu et bien tant que le problème
ne menace pas directement les tarifs et
le régime et bien l'Etat russe fait
comme si ce problème n'existait pas
merci Elena et à la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau vu de Russie